Florida Governor Ron DeSantis says it
could take years for the state to
recover from the Hurricane's Devastation
Ian struck the Southwest part of Florida
as a category 4 hurricane on Wednesday
with 150 mile per hour winds roads and
bridges were wiped out scores of homes
and businesses and some Coastal
communities were left unrecognizable
Chris Van Cleave is in Sarasota and
joins us now Chris good morning
Dana good morning there's still an
estimated 1.3 million people across
Florida that are in the dark I want to
show you some of the tens of thousands
of power Crews that have masks here that
are working around the clock to try to
get the lights back on and while they
are working so hard there are parts of
Florida that are still being hit with
flooding
is there anybody in there rescues like
this one near Orlando continue as
Florida deals with the aftermath of
hurricane Ian good yep five Orange
County sheriff's deputies rescued a
woman from 10 foot high flood waters
after her car was Swept Away by an
extreme current
the storm made landfall Wednesday
afternoon along the Southwest coast of
Florida shredding homes flooding
communities and knocking out Bridges
Florida Governor Ron DeSantis focused on
recoveries the storm made its way to the
Carolinas you had people immediately
descend onto the scene particularly in
Southwest Florida there's a life rescue
making sure people are okay following up
on any type of calls and there's been
really a Herculean effort I am 67. with
the five years now it's gone and it's
underwater
I don't know what to say
it's all too new yet we'll still figure
out what we're doing this place is
definitely shot President Biden
authorized the federal government to
cover the cost of clearing the massive
debris left in the wake of the hurricane
it's likely the rank among the worst in
the nation's history
you have all seen the scene on
television homes and property wiped out
it's going to take months years to
rebuild and while many have been through
storms before
it doesn't make it any easier it's not
my first hurricane but it's my first
total loss
so I'm trying to be brave I pretty much
I think I've lost everything I own
this whole Community is devastated and
just kind of just going to move on and
start a new chapter that's all we can do
it's been about 48 hours since the Gulf
Coast has seen any rain still Friday
there were hundreds of evacuations just
down the road from here because of flash
flooding all that water has to drain
into somewhere it has closed a section
of Interstate 75 to everybody but First
Responders that's a key route into Fort
Myers meaning many people aren't able to
get back home right now Michelle yeah to
get back home to clean up to recover
Chris Van Cleave thank you so much